[Music]
we are back
and it's story time here on the dr john
eloni show
i try to say that in my least creepy
voice did i get it no it's kind of
creepy it's good it's good
all right so
today we're going to
discuss
a classic and i know this is going to
get me in trouble with the moms across
the world
it's called love you forever by robert
munch
munch is that he say it
munchkuch
illustrated by sheila mcgraw
and normally you would think i love this
book it's got a child playing in a
toilet i think that's hilarious but i'm
gonna read it here we go
not all of it mind you it's a thousand
pages oh here's my pipe
i don't even know whose pipe this is is
that yours sorry about that man
i'm fairly certain i'm covered free all
right
a mother held her new baby
and very slowly rocked him back and
forth back and forth back and forth and
while she held him she's saying i lo
i'll love you forever i'll like you for
always as long as i'm living my baby
you'll be
the baby grew and he grew and he grew
and he grew he grew all right we get it
he grew until he was two years old and
he ran all around the house he pulled
all the books off the shelves he pulled
all the food out of the refrigerator and
he took his mother's watch and flushed
it down the toilet
sometimes his mother would say this kid
is driving me crazy well that's rude
but at night when the two-year-old was
quiet
she opened the door to his room kind of
creepily stalked a little bit like a
murderer crawled across the floor looked
up over the side of his bed
as if he was really asleep and if he was
really asleep she picked him up and
rocked him back and forth back and forth
back and forth while she rocked him
she's saying i'll love you forever i'll
like you for always as long as i'm
living my baby you'll be and for if
you've ever read a book to a kid
at night
when you've got stuff to do
you this is the part when you realize oh
my gosh this is going to take like 30
minutes because this book goes on
forever so i'm just going to fast
forward
the kid is in middle school
she's still picking him up hugging him
back and forth back and forth back and
forth
um he's still trashing the place only
now he's got booze and microphones and
pizza and kids
ah but back and forth back and forth she
still crawls around on the floor
sneaking up on his bed
my mom every girl
and then
this is when the book
in my opinion gets off the rails
that teenager grew and he grew and he
grew until he became a grown-up man
he left home and got a house across town
but sometimes on dark nights
the mother got into her car and she
drove across town
has anyone ever seen the shining
and if all the lights out in the sun's
house of all the lights in her son's
house were out she opened his bedroom
window crawled across the floor and
looked up over the side of his bed
this is when you call 9-1-1 folks if
there's a woman crawling into your
window call 9-1-1
and if you think i think that's my
elderly mother especially call 9-1-1 for
you because you'll probably see
oh god okay so
then she crawls she gets a ladder on top
of her car by the way so she's now
breaking entering into her grown man
son's house
through the window
and this cat still sleeping in a single
bed that's a whole other conversation
it yeah we needed that yeah
okay so
um
if all the lights in her son's house
were out she opened his bedroom window
crawled across the floor and looked up
over the side of his bed
if that great big man was really asleep
which suggests that there was times that
she crawled across the floor and he was
awake and she was like sorry son see you
later and she just crawled back out the
window but alas if he was truly asleep
maybe he'd had four or five ambien if
that great big man was really asleep and
she rocked him back and forth and back
and forth and back and forth and while
she rocks she's saying
i'll love you forever
like a stalker
or murderer perhaps
i'll love you for always as long as i'm
living my baby you'll be
oh boy
then he comes around
and hugs his mom it's a beautiful ending
so i think it's just important to call
out the serial killer part in the middle
of this beautiful story she loved your
little boy
and then um he hugged her his mom
it's awesome it's beautiful
when the son came home that night he
stood for a long time at the top of the
stairs
oh no
this is how generational trauma gets
transmitted kids
now he picks up his daughter
and starts the whole creepy thing over
again
oh no
i'm gonna re i'm gonna reimagine the
ending then he picked up his daughter
out of her crib
and looked at her and said i love you
baby and i always will
but i'm not just gonna sneak in and
break into your house and you're an
adult woman and climb through your
bedroom window and crawl across your
floor
and wait till you're passed out of sleep
and then hug you
a lot
it's not going to do that
i'm going to raise you
to be able to verbalize your needs
and to let you know that i love you at
all times
that's i love you forever by uh bob
munch
way to go bob